[Musique]
un peu beaucoup passionnément les
présidents et les Français documentaires
réalisés par Michel Moreau et Dimitri
qui effley ou comment une fois passé le
foride des victoires des relations
souvent ambiguës rarement apaisées
s'établissent au fil du temps entre les
Français et leur président une relation
bien particulière on l'a vu une sorte de
je t'aime moi non plus sur laquelle nous
allons revenir plus au-delà maintenant
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
de débat doc avec vous pour commencer
Roland cairolle bienvenue elle faisait
politologue votre dernier livre paru
chez Calmon Levi s'intitule mon voyage
au cœur de la Cinquième République il a
été réalisé avec le professeur en
communication Arnaud Mercier Cécile
cornudate avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste politique éditorialiste au
quotidien Les Échos c'est VOUS AUSSI qui
aviez écrit réalisé un documentaire en
deux volets consacrés au fameux débat
d'entre-deux tours des présidentielles
que nous avions d'ailleurs eu plaisir de
présenter dans cette même émission et
puis enfin Renaud Elite avec nous
bienvenue bonjour vous êtes journaliste
éditorialiste politique dans la matinale
de nos confrères de France Info où vous
animez également les informer du matin
vous présenter par ailleurs le 28
minutes c'est chaque vendredi et chaque
samedi soir chez notre confrère Darty
votre dernier livre s'intitule lui
anatomie d'une trahison la gauche contre
le progresse un ouvrage publié aux
éditions l'Observatoire pour commencer
cette émission et après ce documentaire
que nous venons de voir ensemble ce
graphique qui est basé sur une une étude
d'opinion qui a été réalisée pour le
compte de la Fondation Jean Jaurès par
l'institut Ifop étude réalisée à
l'automne
2021 voici quelles sont les présidents
le plus apprécié par les sondés à cette
époque Charles de Gaulle arrive très
largement tête 31%, Jacques Chirac
François Mitterrand assez loin derrière
et puis en fin de classement toute le
classement Valéry Giscard d'Estaing 4%
seulement et Georges Pompidou 3% à noter
tout de même que Jacques Chirac gagne du
terrain plus on s'éloigne dans le temps
en 2013 il est arrivé derrière François
Mitterrand on voit dans sur ce graphique
qui est maintenant le deuxième dans
l'esprit des des français Jacques Chirac
surtout soutenu à l'occasion de ce
sondage par les sympathisants du
rassemblement national d'une part et de
la France insoumise d'autre part les
sympathisants du parti les républicains
lui préfère encore et toujours Charles
de Gaulle on va commencer cette émission
par ordre chronologique d'abord la prise
de pouvoir avec
domites finalement qui sont aussi
abordés dans ce film c'est ce sont les
100 jours et le fameux état de grâce
ensuite on parlera évidemment de des
premiers chaos des premières crises
auxquelles il faut faire face lorsqu'on
est président de la République et c'est
répercussions évidemment
du côté des Français et puis le revoir
la fin la fin du pouvoir du côté de
l'Elysée Roland Cayrol l'état de grâce
est fini nous dit ce documentaire
premier mythe qui tombe au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance dans le temps sous
cette cinquième république oui des tas
de Grasse c'est bien fini
ça à jouer pour les premiers présidents
ça a joué pour de Gaulle c'est un jouet
pour Pompidou ça a joué pour Mitterrand
et petit à petit à partir du deuxième
mandat de Mitterrand ça c'est face
on explique comment ça pour les premiers
c'est que c'est compréhensible les
Français sont contents de voter à
l'élection présidentielle au suffrage
universel direct c'est l'heure élection
il continue à le dire aujourd'hui ils
veulent pas qu'on la leur enlève ils ont
le sentiment qu'ils l'ont arraché au
pouvoir politique ils ont oublié que
c'est le général de Gaulle qui ne leur a
proposé donc c'est l'heure élection ils
y vont et ils ont le sentiment que pour
la première fois dans leur histoire ils
sont directement les responsables de ce
qui arrive donc on est content de
l'avoir on lui fait a priori confiance
et on n'est pas très pas surprises sont
des hommes qu'on connaît on les retrouve
au pouvoir ils font à peu près ce qu'on
pensait qu'il ferait et puis petit à
petit les Français sont déçus par la
politique ils sont déçus par les hommes
et les femmes politiques et des hommes
de plus ce fameux état de grâce et donc
il y a plus ça moi je me souviens d'une
conversation c'est sous Sarkozy que
l'effondrement devient-elle que il
devient structurel je me souviens d'une
discussion avec le responsable des
études d'opinion auprès de Nicolas
Sarkozy un collègue sondeur et on se
disait en sortant d'une émission de
radio il va falloir s'habituer à ce que
dans ce pays 30% de popularité c'est la
norme on n'est pas un pays dans lequel
on donne des codes de popularité au
président partout les cotes dans tous
les pays occidentaux ont eu tendance à
baisser elles sont plus faibles chez
nous que partout ailleurs parce que
cette défiance à l'égard du politique
est plus forte qu'ailleurs nous sommes
un pays grognon pessimiste
lorsque les politiques font pas leur
boulot qui sont pas à la hauteur qui
n'entendent pas nos messages et donc
évidemment ça porte d'abord sur le
principal responsable quotidien qui est
le président qui est celui qui doit tout
faire état de grâce et sans premier jour
les fameux sons jour mais les 100 jours
ils doivent permettre de mettre en
oeuvre qui ont été les promesses
électorales et là très souvent se rend
compte que il y a eu des déceptions du
côté des Français oui moi je pense que
ce que montre très bien ce film c'est le
grand malentendu sur l'élection
présidentielle je sais pas s'il y a un
autre pays où on aurait pu faire un film
comme ça en parlant de la relation
passionnelle vous disiez je t'aime moi
non plus c'est vraiment ça et ça et les
données par l'élection au suffrage
universel on parle d'hommes providentiel
on l'a vu il y a tout le registre
amoureux la campagne électorale c'est
une sorte de grande cour où le candidat
essaye de plaire on est dans un registre
vraiment qui est celui de l'affectif du
cœur et une du coup qui laisse quand
même passer pendant la campagne au
second plan les idées on n'est pas le
registre de la réflexion je pense qu'une
Angela Merkel par exemple
elle elle va davantage devant les
Allemands en disant voilà je vais faire
ci je vais faire ça on aurait des
documentaires sur est-ce qu'elle a bien
fait est-ce qu'elle a répondu aux
attentes non nous on fait un
documentaire sur pourquoi on s'aime pour
quand on s'aime pas c'est quand même
très particulier je pense que c'est lié
à l'élection au suffrage universel au
départ c'est bien expliqué dans le film
le général de Gaulle le fait pour avoir
de la force pour faire mais très vite je
pense donc ça n'est qu'un moyen cette
élection mais très vite le moyen de bien
une fin on fait campagne on veut être
élu pour être aimé pour et on oublie un
peu le faire qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire et on a
l'impression que ça passe un peu au
second plan dans une campagne électorale
toutes les promesses il y en a des
promesses mais plus savables puis on dit
il en faut quelques-unes trois quatre
qu'on retient etc mais au fond c'est pas
ça on ne parle pas à l'intelligence des
gens à leur réflexion et d'où la l'état
de grâce qui diminue au fur et à mesure
d'où l'impression que les promesses sont
jamais tenues parce que plus on est déçu
plus les les promesses dans la campagne
sont exorbitantes et on les fait pas
donc moi je pense qu'il y a un
malentendu lié au fait que ce choix du
président il est fait sur le mauvais
registre il est fait sur le registre
affectif le fait de tenir ses promesses
électorales ça a bien marché pour
François Mitterrand alors il a fait une
campagne sur la rupture la rupture avec
le capitalisme en l'occurrence mais vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et pendant 18
mois c'est un record sous la Cinquième
il a il a obtenu une coop popularité au
dessus de 50% pendant 18 mois puis
arrive le fameux tournant de la rigueur
et puis là on voit cette cote baissée
puis à l'inverse François Hollande à la
plus forte cote lorsqu'il est élu et
c'est lui qui baisse le plus rapidement
très rapidement un délotone 2012 on voit
sa cote passer aux alentours des 40% le
respect des engagements tenus proposés
pendant l'accompagner électorale
beaucoup plus vite il y a un cas
particulier qui est effectivement celui
de Jacques Chirac où il y a une vraie
attente parce que son élection survient
à la fin d'un second setenat extrêmement
long une fin extrêmement pénible et
Jacques Chirac est l'un de ceux c'est
pas le seul mais l'un de ceux qui va
mettre le plus en scène quasiment le
revirement si moi après c'est à dire de
la fracture sociale au virage du 26
octobre 1995 les déficits puis la
réforme Juppé et là je pense que c'est
une vraie césure et que derrière
effectivement l'état de grâce n'existe
plus ou quasiment plus pour ses
successeurs que ce soit enfin de façon
quasi éphémère en tout cas et c'est le
premier point et puis un autre point que
montre très bien aussi le documentaire
me semble-t-il c'est la désacralisation
de la fonction c'est à dire qu'à la fois
il y a ce qui expliquait si c'est le
candidat d'un instant il y a une attente
de la part des Français c'est un peu un
lieu commun de dire que président de la
République est un monarque que
républicain mais c'est vrai qu'on en
attend tout en quelque sorte on élit
quelqu'un qu'on considère comme un homme
providentiel qui serait capable de tout
et dès lors qu'on l'a élu d'ailleurs on
se dépêche de taper dessus c'est l'homme
providentiel
et en même temps il y a une vraie
désacralisation qui me semble-t-il et
spectaculaire à partir de 2007 à partir
de l'élection 2007 qui marquait un vrai
tournant et qui de Nicolas Sarkozy puis
à François Hollande puis Emmanuel Macron
c'est perpétuer à la fois dans le
comportement quotidien au pouvoir dans
la façon dont se comportement était
raconté aussi par par les médias et
maintenant au sens large l'impact des
réseaux sociaux évidemment est
spectaculaire notamment et puis la façon
dont les Français désormais regardent ce
monarque dont ils ont aucune hâte c'est
de pouvoir taper dessus et de considérer
qu'il est pas à la hauteur j'observe que
vous faites la même remarque que ce
documentaire désacralisation de la
fonction présidentielle vous l'adaptez à
partir de Nicolas Sarkozy donc c'est un
oui ça ne commence pas à ce moment-là
mais je pense qu'il y a une vraie césure
et qui n'a fait que que que se
poursuivre depuis est-ce que c'est
désacralisation évoquée dans ce
documentaire à l'instant par Renault de
lune n'est pas aussi dû à l'instauration
du quinquennat qui a succédé
la présidentialisation du pouvoir qui a
incarné notamment Nicolas Sarkozy à une
espèce de banalisation de la situation
française on a un mandat comme les
autres à peu près 5 ans on a une
conjonction de la de la tenue des
élections voilà on a une vie politique
qui est moins originale que ce qui avait
la France antérieurement ce qui me
paraît frappant c'est que beaucoup de
choses qu'on attribue à cette cinquième
République ou à ces institutions
existent ailleurs
la personnalisation du pouvoir la
médiatisation le rôle des réseaux
sociaux il est partout ce qui se battent
en France un régime parlementaire ce qui
demande une sixième république par
exemple qui regarde ce qui se passe dans
tous les pays européens qui nous
entourent qui sont tous des régimes
parlementaires parlementaires à
commencer par la Grande-Bretagne c'était
un régime purement parlementaire on a la
même personnalisation du pouvoir les
élections se font sur la personnalité de
celui qui va être Premier ministre
chancelier ou président du Conseil on ne
vote pas d'abord pour un parti on vote
en même temps de plus en plus et y
compris avec de plus en plus
d'affectivité comme dirait Cécile pour
des gens qui vont nous incarner et si
vous votez aujourd'hui conservateur vous
savez que c'est pour richissounac pas
pour quelqu'un d'autre et même lorsque
Cécile parlait de dongleb Merkel il y
avait une personnalisation
qui était pas celle à l'époque l'épreuve
du pouvoir elle l'a construit dans le
pouvoir et pas dans la construit une
personnalisation très à rebours de ce
que nous faisons nous-mêmes dans son hlm
avec son mari faisant la cuisine allant
faire ses courses mais c'était quand
même incroyablement personnalisé donc il
y a une espèce de demande de proximité
des gens il y a une volonté de révérence
envers le pouvoir qui doit nous rendre
service être bon et il est de moins en
moins bon mais en même temps cette
volonté d'une incarnation qui
franchement dépasse de beaucoup je crois
la Cinquième République et qui a
traversé l'ensemble de démocratie pour
le meilleur et parfois pour le pire on
va voir un premier extrait du
documentaire Mitterrand dans la
tourmente de la crise scolaire autour de
sa réforme de l'éducation c'est en 1984
on va amorcer ce qui deviendra une loi
des reins des présidents de la
République sous la 5ème c'est une
impopularité toujours plus rapide
toujours plus puissante on en a marre de
Mitterrand et de patients
ça n'est pas en supprimant
l'enseignement privé que vous allez
donner de la qualité à l'enseignement
laïque moi je pense que c'est une bonne
loi je pense que les jugé de façon très
injustes il y a plus d'un million de
personnes dans la rue et François
Mitterrand à ce moment-là le sens
politique tout simplement de reculer de
comprendre que il ne peut pas imposer ce
système qu'il n'y arrivera pas que les
résistances sont beaucoup trop fortes
bon mais cette opinion que j'ai il
existe qu'il n'est pas partagée il
reculera François Mitterrand il changera
le Premier ministre d'ailleurs quelques
quelques jours quelques semaines après
tiens Mauroy Sotra et c'est Laurent
fabuscule du succédera à Matignon suite
à cette fameuse crise les présidents et
la crise là on est dans le on est dans
le dur comme l'ont dit c'est à dire que
il faut réagir vis-à-vis de Français qui
sont mécontents alors on pourrait
évoquer on évoque 84 vous pourrez
évoquer plus près de nous la crise des
gilets jaunes et bien d'autres
les présidents face à la crise
de ce que je disais à partir du moment
où c'est construit la relation sur de
l'affectif quand ça se passe mal ça
devient passionnel et ça devient très
difficile pour un président de tenir on
voit qu'effectivement François
Mitterrand recule et d'ailleurs souvent
après pour réparer la crise on l'a
beaucoup vu avec Emmanuel Macron on
revient auprès des Français pour refaire
une sorte de campagne et leur remontrer
qu'on les aime puisque on s'était mal
compris à un moment où vous faites
référence au grand débat instauré par
les chefs de l'État après les gilets
jaunes la réforme des retraites où il a
eu besoin de de faire des mini débats
donc il faut toujours garder ce ce fil
et effectivement c'est je pense que
c'est d'autant plus difficile
quand vient la crise de la régler que on
est sur ce registre pas de du
raisonnement économique pas de pas de
pas de la construction d'une d'un
programme de gouvernement et quand il y
a un malentendu et bien il se solde dans
vraiment la déchirure et la sanction
électorale qui suit
je pense que c'est
d'autres enfin c'est même de plus en
plus difficile avec le temps c'est à
dire que si j'ose dire c'est c'était
assez facile d'être présent dans la
République dans les années 60 ou deux
années 70 sièges je pense que et on le
voit ces spectaculaires ces dernières
années l'addition de crise ne dépend pas
aussi uniquement des situations
nationales et aujourd'hui la France est
par définition une puissance plus
dépendante sur le plan économique sur le
plan des échanges sur le plan des flux
migratoires sur le plan évidemment par
exemple des des conséquences du défi
climatique et bien d'autres et on voit
bien les crises aujourd'hui d'abord elle
se nourrissent de ce terreau c'est à
dire de ce de cette relation un peu
perverti dès le début parce qu'elle est
forcément professionnels qu'on essayait
de décrire depuis tout à l'heure donc il
y a aussi propre là à notre mode de
fonctionnement de fonctionnement de
l'opinion une forme aussi parfois un peu
d'infantilisme de l'opinion c'est-à-dire
que parfois les électeurs se comportent
aussi un peu comme des enfants qui
effectivement se dépêchent de vouloir
taper sur celui qu'ils ont choisi voilà
de
bascule très vite donc de la vénération
les détestations et de surprendre on le
voit depuis maintenant plusieurs
plusieurs années bien les crises
s'additionnent se multiplient me
semble-t-il à mesure aussi que la France
est dépendante et c'est naturel de son
environnement lequel est d'ailleurs
aussi foncièrement en crise et on voit
bien que la plupart des défis qui se
posent à la France aujourd'hui sont des
filles qui se posent à l'Europe aimait
bien au-delà et donc c'est vrai que le
président aujourd'hui se heurte encore
plus à il cumulent si vous voulez ces
deux dimensions la dimension
passionnelle proprement française liée à
nos caractéristiques nationales aussi à
nos institutions à la pratique de ces
institutions et puis le fait que je
pense qu'il est beaucoup plus difficile
aujourd'hui de gérer un pays comme la
France pense que c'était plus facile de
construire le gaullisme même le ou le
même le mytherandisme dans un seul pays
si j'osais
que c'est techniquement aussi plus
compliqué chaque décision entraîne des
conséquences financières juridiques et
très compliqué à expliquer aux gens
il s'agit pas seulement de savoir
retirer les méthodes les choses un peu
plus il s'agit de l'expliquer
Mitterrand ce qui fait bien ce qu'on
vient de voir dans votre extrait c'est
que il dit moi cette loi je la trouvais
bonne
mais vous n'en voulez pas on va donc
l'enlever et ça c'est quand même très
astucieux je me suis pas laissé
convaincre mais c'est vous le peuple
souverain et ça c'est très important de
savoir quand on doit céder ce qu'on doit
céder et comment l'expliquer on vit des
crises comme celle de 84 c'est rare plus
d'un million de personnes dans les rues
c'est un record de manifestation en
France dans 95 sur Accès Président
on est amené à céder de temps en temps
aujourd'hui on vit dans une succession
de mini crise où le pouvoir se demande
en permanence qu'est-ce que je cède à
qui est-ce que en faisant ça j'ai
quelques députés elle est en plus à
l'Assemblée est-ce qu'on faisant ça je
peux avoir une chance que quelqu'un à
gauche me suivent mais c'est devenu
extrêmement compliqué à suivre et à
comprendre par les gens donc je crois
que l'important n'est pas de céder de
montrer qu'on sait de faire un effort
pour s'adapter de faire un peu plus
d'équilibre vous allez pouvoir comme les
Allemands nous le suggèrent en
permanence c'est vraiment d'expliquer
cela vous savez lorsque Hollande s'est
effondré dans les sondages c'était pour
cette question que poser les gens au
sondeur mais où va-t-il il nous a fait
campagne sur mon ennemi c'est la finance
il fait une politique purement trop
entreprise où va-t-il esquisser où il va
il l'a fait dès l'automne 2012
et à cet élargissement de la question
mais où va-t-il qui nous explique donc
je veux réagir là dans ces réflexions
parce que la grande différence entre les
débuts de la 5ème et aujourd'hui c'est
l'extrême médiatisation l'accélération
du temps le président ne peut plus
rester en retrait comme y rester encore
autant de François Mitterrand du coup
quand il parle ça a beaucoup moins de
force parce que en réalité
il parle tout le temps et du coup il est
pas entendu sur ses explications or dans
une relation amoureuse il faut toujours
garder une distance etc pour entretenir
le désir et ce désir est rompu en
réalité je pense depuis le vers Nicolas
Sarkozy le tournant du siècle à cause de
cette médiatisation et cette peut-être
le quinquennat aussi il en fera en tout
cas l'accélération médiatique du temps
politique parce que le temps politique
n'est pas le temps médiatique
en tout cas pour mesurer les les effets
d'un choix d'un CAP choisi sur le plan
économique par exemple on voit bien que
les attentes de l'opinion d'une part ils
puissent depuis le temps médiatique ce
que vous appelez le temps bien que si
évidemment sont beaucoup plus rapides
que par exemple si on prend l'exemple de
François Hollande il a indexé tout son
quinquennat sur vous souvenez sa volonté
sa promesse d'infléchir la courbe du
chômage il a pas eu le temps si j'ose
dire alors il y avait pas que ça il y
avait pas il a pas eu c'est pas heurté
uniquement c'est difficile là dans son
quinquennat mais on peut penser en tout
cas que sur ce sujet là
l'inflexion qui a été la sienne la
politique et la mise en œuvre
elle a fini par porter oui mais sous le
sous son successeur lequel a continué
d'ailleurs ce cap là il y a une
filiation en termes de politique de
l'offre qui est assez manifeste entre
François Hollande et Emmanuel Macron
donc c'est vrai que le temps médiatique
et le temps des attentes de l'opinion
qui est calqué sur ce temps médiatique
et puis on le voit sur l'ensemble des
crises qu'affrontent l'exécutif ces
dernières années il y a une forme
d'urgence à laquelle effectivement
l'action politique a du mal à répondre
aussi rapidement et de façon aussi
concrète et c'est vrai que dans le cas
de François Hollande qu'on évoquait je
crois que ce sont greffés aussi
plusieurs éléments et notamment on
évoquait la désacralisation qui remonte
qui lui est antérieure et c'est vrai que
ça a été manifeste avec François
Hollande avec aussi et d'ailleurs ça
c'est très présent dans le documentaire
d'être un président normal le choix
d'une présidente normale mais comment
être un président normal dès lors que
tout remonte au président et que le
président est quasiment le seul à se
retrouver en première ligne à devoir
faire justement la pédagogie y compris
de façon extrêmement caricaturale et
ratée on a en mémoire un des éléments
qui a contribué aussi à la chute de
popularité de France Hollande c'était la
façon dont il a géré médiatiquement
l'affaire dite leonarda où il s'est
retrouvé lui-même en première ligne à
aller dialoguer avec une enfant avec le
résultat dont on se souvient à la
télévision oui je peux que
je voulais vous poser c'est bon
début prise de pouvoir
la cote de popularité elle descend pas
systématiquement jusqu'à la fin du
mandat il y a des moments dans
l'exercice du pouvoir ou une cote de
popularité peut remonter vous avez des
exemples assez précis tout de même ça se
passe avec le président avec le
président actuel dans les moments il va
faire de telle profondeur on se demande
si vous a pas atteindre des codes de
négatives bah il reprend deux trois
quatre points on a des allers-retours
comme si de temps en temps les Français
eux-mêmes se disaient bon quand même
il fait le job quoi et il y a il y a pas
beaucoup de bienveillance envers
politique mais de temps en temps il y a
les excès des autres
moi je crois qu'il y a ça il y a sur un
champ concurrentiel qui est la politique
évidemment il y a celui qui est le
premier objet de nos ressentiments c'est
le Président il est là pour tout faire
et donc ce qui se fait bien c'est grâce
à nous ce qui se fait de mal c'est à
cause de lui ça c'est la loi du genre
mais on regarde les autres en ce moment
par exemple a faillite d'opinion de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et sûrement une
explication du fait que les autres sont
regardés avec un peu plus de
bienveillance il y a des moments où ça
ne passe plus quoi
80% nous dit l'ifope de gens trouvent
que la façon dont Mélenchon gère la
crise n'est pas bonne 80% c'est quand
même incroyable pour l'idée de
l'opposition et voilà il se passe des
choses comme ça il y a des moments où
les gens se disent attention même chose
les gens disent il y a un boulevard pour
le rassemblement national à cause de la
politique du pouvoir peu clair etc et
Tac sera un sondage il y a une quinzaine
de jours trois semaines dans le dans le
JDD qui dit que une majorité des
Français continuent à avoir peur de
l'arrivée du rassemblement national au
pouvoir donc il y a quand même des
réflexes sur lesquels l'actualité nous
permet de rebondir parce qu'on regarde
pas seulement le président agir mais on
regarde un peu tout ce qui se passe on
va voir un deuxième extrait du
documentaire c'est le revoir le fameux
au revoir de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
nous sommes en mai 1980 je souhaite que
la providence veille sur la France
pour son bonheur
pour son bien et pour sa grandeur
au revoir
quand on revoit cette image c'est
interminable ce chemin qui mène à la
porte de sortie et là il a eu l'occasion
de dire lui-même c'était pas rendu
compte à quel point c'était loin alors
quitter le pouvoir
comment faut-il pour sortir la tête
haute on voit que c'est que très
compliqué pour les présidents
c'était le pouvoir la tête haute
finalement avec un code de popularité
qui ressemblerait un temps soit peu avec
celle qu'on avait au début de l'exercice
du pouvoir à l'Élysée en plus la donne
qui est un peu changé c'est que
maintenant on a des présidents qui
partent jeunes du pouvoir et qui ont en
tête peut-être de pouvoir revenir on
voit que ça a été présent alors chez
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing il est jamais
arrivé et puis depuis chez Nicolas
Sarkozy François Hollande donc il y a
l'idée de se ménager une possibilité de
retour si un jour par le miracle d'un
trou de souris ou je ne sais quoi ce
serait à nouveau possible donc faut
quand même tout le monde travaille sa
sortie on a beaucoup dit par exemple que
la sortie de Nicolas Sarkozy avait été
très réussi avec tout de suite faisant
un monde honorable leur reconnaissance
et erreurs pas du tout d'arrogance pas
du tout je quitte la vie politique
prudent et humble qui lui ressent on a
toujours dit il était presque meilleur
dans ses sorties que
dans tous les autres moments donc voilà
maintenant il y a vraiment l'idée de de
ne pas s'abîmer dans la sortie parce
qu'on sait depuis Giscard qu'on peut
s'abîmer durablement oui il y a la mise
en scène qui est resté évidemment dans
les mémoires que du côté caricatural un
gadget totalement surné qui illustre
aussi l'époque c'est-à-dire qu'à ce
moment là vous souvenir à quel point
l'alternance c'était d'un côté pour ceux
qui avaient soutenu François Mitterrand
la promesse qu'on allait passer de
l'ombre à la lumière comme le disait
Jack Lang et puis de l'autre côté
c'était l'apocalypse avec des milliers
d'exilés fiscaux qui ont pris le chemin
de la Suisse donc le renvoi de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing s'inscrit dans ce
contexte le d'où le siège vide derrière
comme si le pouvoir qui lui succédait
était illégitime c'est vrai qu'on en est
plus là fort heureusement avec cette
cette propension effectivement de celui
qui est battu à ne jamais dire
définitivement au revoir il y a aussi
une audience prudence de quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais été présent à la République
mais c'est Lionel Jospin dont évidemment
le souvenir c'est ancré quand même ce
départ au soir du matin d'avril 2002
comme un contre-exemple pour nombre de
de de ceux qui ont depuis Dieu qui était
le pouvoir même si d'ailleurs je pense
on l'oublie à lui-même essayer de
revenir jusqu'en 2006 en tout cas il
faut toujours se ménager une porte de
sortie enfin une porte de sortie qui
peut être une porte de retour en quelque
sorte une porte d'entrée et on va vivre
ça peut-être de façon encore plus
spectaculaire dans les années qui
viennent puisque pour la première fois
on va avoir un ancien président de la
République qui pourra pas se représenter
en 2022 mais qui aura moins de 50 ans il
aura 49 ans au moment où il va quitter
le pouvoir avec son nombre qui va sans
aucun doute planer sur la suite et y
compris sur 2027 ou après donc ça ça va
être un nouveau cas de figure après on
voit différents cas de figure de fin de
mandat avec aussi des fins de mandat
parfois extrêmement pénibles à cause de
la durée à cause de l'âge à cause de la
maladie voilà il y a eu le cas de
François Mitterrand il y a eu celui de
Jacques Chirac aussi qui aujourd'hui
effectivement semble plébisciter par les
Français dans les sondages mais dont la
fin de mandat de 2005 à 2007 entre entre
la maladie entre la défaite aux conseils
au référendum sur la conscient
européenne et plein d'autres avatars
avaient été elle aussi cette fin de
mandat extrêmement pénible l'Ifop a
aussi réalisé une étude lors cette fois
depuis le début de la cinquième
république une étude pour connaître le
niveau de satisfaction des Français
envers leur président le moins populaire
dans le cadre de cette étude de tous les
présidents c'est François Hollande or
comme par hasard c'est c'est celui qui
le seul d'ailleurs qui qui va renoncer
c'était en décembre 2016 d'ailleurs revu
ce renoncement c'est comme ça qu'on a
appelé cette intervention de François
Hollande dans le documentaire que nous
venons de voir donc il y a pas de
surprise c'est-à-dire le plus
impopulaire
il a compris que il ne reviendrait pas
la renonciation ça n'ajoute pas à la
gloire d'un personnage reconnaître qu'on
est même pas en capacité de retourner
devant les urnes c'est un aveu d'échec
quand même terrible moi ce que je crois
c'est que de toute façon quelque soit la
façon dont ils disent ou pas au revoir
la leçon c'est qu'on ne revient pas
alors je sais bien que Trump va
peut-être revenir aux États-Unis je sais
bien que Berlusconi qui n'était pas
président de la République est revenu
vers trois fois mais enfin la loi de nos
démocraties et singulièrement l'un nôtre
c'est que on les aime pas tellement pour
imaginer les revoir aux États-Unis
on ne voit pas les perdants on ne revoit
pas les perdants très peu à peu près
dans aucun pays à peu près dans aucun
pays ils ont fait leur mandat bien ou
mal en général plutôt mal donc on n'a
pas envie de les revoir et ce qui est
incroyable c'est que eux ils croient
tous ils ont suffisamment marqué
qu'il y en a plus
les règles et puis ils ont le sentiment
que eux ils ont ils se sont pas mal
débrouillés mais que quand ils regardent
les autres ils ont le sentiment que
c'est des nains que eux ils ont compris
au pouvoir des choses extrêmement
importantes moi je suis très frappé je
suis on a bien vu que Nicolas Sarkozy
voulait revenir que Giscard a tout fait
pour revenir que François Hollande
aujourd'hui crois qu'il va revenir que
des premiers ministres dont on a à peine
vu qu'ils ont été premier ministre je
vois forcément sur la marche d'après on
en fait des personnages déjà en position
d'être à l'Élysée je crois que ce n'est
pas dans l'univers des Français je crois
que l'univers des Français on change on
en remet d'autres alors on n'a pas
souvent beaucoup de l'idée sur qui ça
pourrait être là par exemple qui
pourrait succéder dans le champ central
de la politique française a Emmanuel
Macron c'est pas clair pour les gens pas
plus pour les journalistes ou les
politologues que pour les que pour les
citoyens mais je crois qu'il faut pas se
leurrer au revoir ça veut dire adieu et
je pense que sur ce point-là on est
aussi imprégné y compris par les tout
début de la section République c'est à
dire en tout cas les responsables
politiques le sont c'est-à-dire que
quand ils espèrent toujours pouvoir
revenir alors qu'effectivement comme les
Italiens Roland Cayrol ce cas de figure
ne se produit plus lié aussi une forme
d'accélération de l'usure du temps
politique et des responsables politiques
eux-mêmes je pense qu'ils sont aussi
imprégnés quelque part de la mystique
goienne c'est-à-dire que les
circonstances pourraient les amener à
revenir tous croissants à un moment ou
un autre et parce que de Gaulle lui-même
est revenu en quelque sorte en 58 mais
évidemment c'est circonstances là qui
est 12 ans après historique voilà des
circonstances historiques bien
particulières elle aussi n'ont pas
vocation à ce problème je pense que ça
imprègne encore et ça renvoie justement
à cette culture de l'homme providentiel
qui continue d'imprégner que auproux et
les institutions et la façon dont ceux
qui sont élus essayent de les pratiquer
c'est une candidate vous allez peut-être
avoir le mot de la fin un an après son
sa réélection Emmanuel Macron une cote
de popularité comprise entre 25 et 28%
selon ses sondage c'est celui qui a la
plus faible cote de popularité en ayant
été élu c'est le seul qui a été réglé
dans quelle situation aujourd'hui
compliquée on voit en plus qu'il est
abonné aux crises donc cela dit à chaque
fois qu'il a pensé sortir d'une crise on
avait une autre qui arrivait et à chaque
fois la crise lui a permis quand même de
ressortir à peu près par le haut d'une
situation qu'on pensait inextricable
donc il est dans une situation politique
difficile il a été le seul président à
pouvoir être élu sans passer par une une
cohabitation donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il est si bas dans les sondages donc
voilà ce qui va pouvoir continuer un
petit peu à agir sachant qu'il peut pas
se représenter sachant que structurer
réellement il est faible et que la
relation avec les Français on en revient
là est abîmé je pense qu'une des leçons
de ce documentaire on a beaucoup parlé
des présidents mais dans ce couple
président français et bien les Français
sont quand même des amoureux très
changeants
euh inconstant et ça explique aussi pas
mal de ce qu'on a vécu je pense ça sera
le mot de la fin comme prévu merci
vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission aujourd'hui
pour parler de cette relation qu'on a
décrypté ensemble entre les Français et
leurs présidents le tout sous la 5e
République vous réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débat doc sur Twitter merci à
Selma Sally qui comme à la coutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission je donne
tout simplement rendez-vous pour un
prochain débat docks ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]